speaking of lies reports last week about
racist graffiti the good old racist
graffiti gambit
um racist graffiti found around campus
at a college
called albion college in michigan the
graffiti said here's what the
graffiti said um kkk white power
die n words please
and um we do exist
kkk and then there was a star of david
with the number six six six written
across i guess it's supposed to be an
anti-semitic thing
um now this was a big deal locally got a
lot of attention the students protested
we got some footage of that there
pretty long line of them this is a small
college it looks like they all came out
look at them all all marching they all
came out to march
against racism on campus
uh and then what does it i don't i don't
have to tell you what happens next do i
you already know you heard racist
graffiti and if you
if you've been paying attention at all
over the last 10 years you know exactly
where this is headed
it was a hoax it was a black student
that wrote the graffiti
you know even without the the history
even without knowing the history you
probably would have already guessed that
this is a hoax
because this just isn't kkk white power
who do you think is is going to
sincerely write that
even if it was an actual white racist
like why would they write that
but as we've covered many times you know
people who want to invent hate crimes
and turn themselves into a victim they
have they have a lot of trouble
doing it persuasively and convincingly
because
they really have not encountered a lot
of racism from white people so they they
don't even know what that would be like
they you know if if if
racism from white people was common in
this country number one you wouldn't
have to invent it
you wouldn't have to make it up and
number two
if you did make it up you would have
encountered it so often
that you should be able to make it up
and impersonate it convincingly
but this is obviously someone who has
never encountered a white racist in his
entire life
he has no idea what a white racist would
say which is good by the way he's never
encountered one that's a great thing we
should celebrate that
so instead he bases it off of like
movies that he saw in tv shows and stuff
that's one way that you know that it's a
hoax and the other way you know it's a
hoax is that
as far as i can remember and correct me
if i'm wrong
at least say this i cannot think in the
last 20 years i cannot think of a single
case
where so-called racist graffiti or a
racist note
left on a receipt or left on someone's
car windshield or slipped under their
door
turned out to be sincere every single
case that i can think of they were all
hoaxes has there been
even one real case i'm assuming
just law of averages there has to have
been right the last 20 years i have to
have been at least a couple um
of these racist graffiti cases that was
actually done by a white person
maybe anyway m live has the report says
albion college and the albion department
of public safety says that a student is
responsible for racist graffiti found in
a dorm last weekend
albion police brought the 21 year old
black male in for questioning on april
6th
the student admitted to creating most of
the graffiti and video evidence from
albion's
campus safety department confirms the
statements made by the student
so i i take it from that that he was on
uh security camera footage they said
video evidence confirms it so
i'm assuming that he that probably he
was right in front
of a of security camera scrolling this
thing
when it comes to hate crime hoaxes
they're really not sending their best
um but here's the response to this from
albion college
and i could be pronouncing the name of
the college wrong never heard of them
before now
but here's what they tweeted this is
this they put they put this out i think
was yesterday
this is after it was already known who
was responsible for this and this is
their tweet
okay they said earlier today we
identified the individual responsible
for the racist and anti-semitic graffiti
in mitchell towers
the student who was acting alone
acknowledged our responsibility for
these act for these incidents
they have been immediately removed from
campus and placed on temporary
suspension while we conduct a full
investigation as part of our student
judicial process
but we know the acts of racism that have
occurred this week are not about one
particular person or one particular
incident
we know that there's a significant
history of racial pain and trauma on
campus
and we're taking action to repair our
community we will change and heal
together as a community because we are
committed to doing the work
right now we encourage all members of
our community to listen respond and care
for one another
and lean on the faculty staff community
members who have been gathering today to
make sure we're supporting you
we have your back okay aside from the
normal tripe about we'll do the work
we're committed the phrase do the work
has become to me
as grading and annoying as the phrase
lived experience
and they're always said by the usually
in the same sentence
um by the the the same sorts of people
i'm surprised lived experience didn't
appear in this statement here
we'll do the work to understand your
lived experience
but do you notice so we got to do the
work we got the buzzwords and everything
you notice what's missing from this
statement
they never say it was a hoax they never
say that it was a black student who did
it
in fact they intentionally give the
impression
that it was a white student they don't
say that but they tie all this
into historic racism racial trauma
so on and so forth they're clearly
trying to give the impression without
saying it that
the graffiti really was done by a white
racist
that's the way the school has decided to
handle it
and um if that doesn't work then they
will
um at least try to disperse the blame
[Music]
you know it's we're not gonna blame this
one individual uh we're gonna blame the
institutions
this this is not this is not about one
particular person
it's about a history of racial pain no
it is definitely about one particular
person it's about the guy who did it
a guy who they say is kicked off a
campus that's good he should also be
charged with a crime
you know a hate crime hoax
is a hate crime i'm not a fan of the
hate crime
designation at all i don't think it
should exist but as long as it does it
should be used equally and in a way
that's
at least sort of coherent and what that
means is that a hate crime hoax should
be considered a hate crime
so it's it is a hate crime against the
group of people that you're trying to
frame
that's what it's a hate crime against so
a black student
putting that graffiti up pretending that
a white racist did it that is a hate
crime against white students
he is trying to inflame hatred towards
the white students
and guilt by association is trying to um
to you know
[Music]
defame them as as racist
[Music]
that's the way we should that's why
these things should be handled well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content